hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
better call Saul season 5 episode 5
preview AMC has released the short
trailer which I'll break down scene by
scene and there's also a sneak peak clip
that shows a conversation with Kim
Wexler
and Kevin and Paige from Mesa Verde
before we get into it this is your
spoiler warning in these videos I talk
about everything that's happened in
better call Saul and Breaking Bad up to
this point and I delve into the extra
bits of information that are out there
in the media they do quite a bit of
behind the scenes videos plus the
insider podcasts that give things a
different perspective and also the
episode titles for the entire season are
out there with episode descriptions so
if you don't like that kind of
information then this video won't be for
you make sure you subscribe before you
leave because I will be covering better
call Saul until the end of the series
next season and in my recap videos I
avoid these types of spoilers episode 5
of season 5 is titled dedicado Oh max it
was written by Heather Marion who has
written by credits for three salt
episodes including the season 2 finale
click and it's directed by Jim McKay who
directed coushatta and season 4 better
call Saul and cancer man in season 1 of
Breaking Bad the episode description
reads Mike takes an impromptu trip out
of town Kim makes a surprising call the
trailer opens with Saul drinking from
his world's second best lawyer cup
outside of mr. eckers residence
it looks like he's preparing to unleash
his plan against Mesa Verde then we see
Mike who's sitting on a log say what am
I doing here the big question at the end
of the last episode was where Mike woke
up exactly he's talking to someone here
that standing in front of him in a way
that we can't identify the person I said
at the end of my 504 recap that I
thought he was probably in Mexico and
the yellow-orange filter they use on
this scene is something we've seen
before when they are filming there Mike
spent time recovering in Mexico after
Gus made his move against the leaders of
the cartel there's a good chance this
man standing in front of him is Gus's
doctor talk about this more
- the scene-by-scene because the title
of the episode and his showing up could
hint that we learn more about mr. Frings
backstory after that we see Howard at
home talking on the phone to Jimmy
he says touching base to see if you had
any thoughts on what we talked about we
see Jimmy make a face on the other end
of the line and we're left to wonder how
Jimmy stunts with the bowling balls will
potentially come back and bite him later
for now it appears that Howard is still
trying to bring him on at HHM which we
know Jimmy is not interested in then we
see Saul talking to the sheriff and
Tucumcari with the construction worker
standing next to them Saul says I'm ever
attackers attorney I'm just dotting the
i's and due diligence this ties in with
a sneak-peek video when Kevin asks if
they're still moving forward with
tearing down mr. eckers house tomorrow
I'm guessing Jimmy has something up a
sleeve that's gonna stop this from
happening later in the trailer there is
a sequence of him mixing chemicals
together which could be leading to him
faking some kind of environmental
concern to stop the demolition there's
another shot where Mike is on the phone
it looks like he's still in Mexico and
he says so you're back to being a lawyer
he's probably talking to Saul but it's
hard to say why he's reaching out to him
at this time since we don't know what
new information Mike is working with I
mean it's probably got something to do
with going after Lalo but we're just not
sure at this point in the next shot it's
difficult to tell exactly what's going
on and who exactly is doing it we just
see hands doing something with wires and
circuitry it could be Mike it's probably
Mike the watch we see looks similar to
the one he wears and I think the yellow
filter is involved here as well but I
don't have a great guess as to what's
going on here at a golf course Kevin
says Kim I know a scam when I see one
this is from the same conversation that
we see in the sneak peak video Kim has a
serious look on her face when he says it
and this cuts to a shot of her in bed
where she looks like she's deep in
thought and possibly worried Jimmy lays
down next to her and it's noticeable
that he's not wearing the same clothes
he's wearing when we see him at a KERS
place they're both fully dressed though
they're come
at the end of the night it looks like
and they're laying in bed where Kim has
something on her mind
the voice-over picks up with Jimmy
saying it's nasty it's personal gets
dangerous over the shots of him mixing
the chemicals together that I mentioned
earlier after that we see Kim and Jimmy
standing in the nail salon where his
office was looking out at the parking
lot we see that there's a car outside
but can only make out the headlights
there are a lot of things that could be
going on here this could be related to
the Acker scam could be Gus's guys or it
could also be related to Lalo and nacho
who we don't see it all in this trailer
as we see that we hear Kim say you know
I worked my ass off to get here you know
that she's saying that inside the
Schweikart and Cokely office but we
can't tell who she's saying it to
there's a quick shot of a cell phone
with a dead battery and what looks like
Mike's hand and a shot of Jimmy
spray-painting
over something that we can't see then
the trailer ends with the shot of Mike
walking outdoors possibly heading back
towards the north
or maybe just hanging out getting better
from his stab wound after episode 4 the
big questions for me all revolve around
Kim and her seemingly awful plan to get
Jimmy involved with the mr. Acker
situation actually I should say Saul as
she is more or less asking for Saul's
help here which seems important since
she hasn't been on board with this
transformation the sneak peek gives us a
longer conversation where to me it looks
like Kim is getting out ahead of the
fact that they are going to find out
that Jimmy is involved so what is Kim
actually planning I said in my last
video I think she might be trying to
torpedo her career she might be trying
to get out of this situation with Mesa
Verde because it's really strange that
she would involve Jimmy and get him to
be a KERS lawyer since everyone will
know that they are connected there are
so many different ways this could go and
it's really exciting part of me thinks
that she's going to dupe Jimmy and
that's gonna be the big thing at the end
of the season is that he's gonna be
going along helping her and he's gonna
realize that he didn't really know what
her overall plan was that's purely
speculation so
I can't back it up with any hard facts
but it's really hard to put together
what Kim's trying to pull off here yes
she probably wants to help mr. Acker but
there has to be more going on in my
opinion the fact that she's standing in
the Schweikart and Cokely office given
that speech that we talked about a
minute ago about working her ass off to
get there if she talking to Schweickart
is she losing her job has she really
messed things up with Mesa Verde is that
what's happening there or is she staging
something with Jimmy it's really hard to
tell this is where the future episode
titles and descriptions come into the
speculation episode six is called Wexler
versus Goodman the description is Kim
tries to pump the brakes on Saul's
latest scheme Mike turns up the heat on
Lalo Episode seven is titled JMM and it
says kim sets things straight with her
clients while jimmy is compromised by
his so she's probably not losing your
job this is all probably something that
is part of the scam that we see here
Wexler vs. Goodman means these two are
gonna see each other in court so what
has Kim planned out that involves that
like the whole thing about this is that
we know Kim is smart and that she likes
to fix things and she's a depth at doing
that so I'm super curious as to what
she's planned out to get around all this
stuff and what her intention is like why
does she really care why is this
important in her story at this moment
I'm sure it is and I'm excited to find
out why it's just hard to see at the
present moment I saw someone mentioned
on reddit that maybe they faked a
breakup I hadn't thought of that
personally but that's a possibility but
my underlying thought is at this point
the more I think about it that Kim's
scheme is grand on the scale that it's
not really about mr. Acker it's about
her in her future and she has things
planned out but she has to bring Saul
into it and that makes it complicated
because a lot of things could possibly
go wrong and I'm definitely interested
to hear what you guys think so let me
know in the comments what you think is
going on here the other big question is
of course what Mike is doing in Mexico
how did it get there the episode is
titled dedicado um
max which means dedicated to max we know
that Gus's business partner and los
Pollos hermanos was named max he was
killed by the cartel this is a huge
thing in Gus's life and so that has to
be related to that in some way if this
is Gus's doctor that we see Mike with
that could be an indication that we're
gonna learn more about what happened in
Chile how Gus ended up being in the
situation he's in or maybe Mike just
understanding that part of what his
motivation is is that the cartel
actually killed his significant other we
don't know that for sure
but it feels like there's definitely
some connection there beyond just
business between those two men we're at
the midway point in the season after
this episode and we're moving into some
interesting territory I would like to
learn more about Gus's backstory as I
think his character needs a little bit
of something going on here since we know
how his story ends and and at times it
has been a problem with Mike and Gus's
side of this show that we do know where
they end up Jimmy's going through this
huge transformation but the two of them
already resemble the people we know them
to be in the Breaking Bad timeline so it
would be nice to have some extra
information there make that side of the
story a little bit more interesting I
think that Mike will ultimately form an
alliance with Gus which we haven't seen
to this point so the foundation of that
could be being built at this moment
it'll be interesting to see how the
Howard storyline moves forward because
of the way things usually work in this
universe you have to imagine that
Jimmy's little bit of acting out what
the bowling balls is going to have
consequences I don't think there's any
version of the story where he goes to
work for HHM but I do expect that there
will be more to be revealed in that side
of things and I think I will leave it
there I'm really curious to see what you
guys think about the upcoming episode so
let me know in the comments please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching we'll talk
to you soon